[Musique]
vre frère oublé son courrier merci
beaucoupous les docteur vous êtes ven
avec un
chien
depirinere avec son
diabè
je bien les
Ch
elle est belle cette femme ils sont pas
un peu bizarres ces
médecins j'aime quelqu'un vous êtes pas
avec votre frère ce soir vous savez on n
pas collé tout le temps on n pas les
frères si moi j'ai dit c'est vous que
j'attendais pourquoi vous dites
n'importe quoi un champ de
Dun un monde nouveau vous avez changé
docteur vous Boris vous avez l'air
heureux aujourd'hui mon Dieu mon amour
cette
mélodie c'est pas de ma faute si on aime
la même femme j'ai besoin de Judi plus
que
lui Bor vous l'aimez bonsoirmit ta
[Applaudissements]
voixf s
les tire la langue
mademoiselle ferme les
yeux